[Musique]
il y a bien longtemps en ga régnait
d'ancien
dieux leurs aléas saisonniers rythmaient
le cours cyclique de la nature
oscillation perpétuelle entre vie mort
et
renaissance une légende sacrée imaginée
par les druides et chantée par les
bardes
empruntant les signeux couloirs du temps
certains de ces dieux pitoresques nous
sont parvenus des siècles plus tard
parfois sous des traits étrangement
familiers et il nous semble alors
reconnaître dans le dieu souverain des
anciens Celtes le modèle du Christ de la
religion
médiévale c'est le cas du célèbre Dieu
aux oiseaux
[Musique]
la Stelle de mou visible au musée de
Dijon est communément daté du 3e siècle
de notre
ère le dieu est un homme d'âge mû son
visage barbu est encadré par deux
oiseaux apparemment des corbeaux perchés
sur ses épaules les becs des deux
volatiles sont tournés vers lui comme
pour lui chuchoter quelque chose à
l'oreille
le dieu barbu debout est habillé à la
paysane avec des bris le pantalon
gaulois et une cape sur le dos il tient
une serpe à la main gauche qui soutient
trois fruits dans un sac en
bandoulière de sa main droite il agrippe
un bâton
noueux près de lui est assis son chien
qui le
regarde on retrouve les mêmes sur un
édicule endommagé trouvé à dent-pierre
sous boue dans la
Nièvre sur le tympan du fronton on voit
au centre le visage barbu du Dieu qui
est encadré par deux
oiseaux dans la niche l'homme est sans
tête il est assis et tient dans sa main
gauche une corbeille de fruits dans la
main droite il tenait peut-être une
serpe ou un maillet enfin à ses pieds se
trouve son
chien ainsi mou et Dampierre présentent
visiblement le même personnage un dieu
au visage encadré par deux oiseaux
accompagné d'un chien et pourvoyeur de
fruits une statue de la fend deoll
présente notre Dieu barbu dans des
vêtements souples et de fines
chaussures
le dieu barbu est couronné il semble
accollé à un arbre et c'est sur la
branche de l'arbre que sont perchés les
deux oiseaux situés de part et d'autre
du visage du
personnage le dieu est accompagné de son
chien qui est ici
tricéphale la constante de ce dieu
singulier et que sa tête est toujours
encadrée par deux
oiseaux
de façon résiduelle on en trouve
plusieurs exemples près d'Alice
[Musique]
saintraine ce Dieu aux oiseau n'est pas
propre à la gauche
il existe aussi chez les Germains une
figurine danoise datée de 900 après
Jésus-Christ présente un dieu assis sur
un trône il est encadré par deux
corbeaux perchés sur les
accoudoirs les deux corbeaux fixent le
visage du
dieu une gravure scandinave montre le
même Dieu à cheval toujours accompagné
de ces deux
corbeaux comme on le sait par les récits
Vikings de Ledda il s'agit
d'Odin
le chaudron de gain d'estrupe est un
objet de culte trouvé dans une tourbière
du Danemark à la fin du 19e siècle il
est communément daté de l'époque du
Christ composé de 13 plaques d'argent le
chaudron présente une facture druidique
évidente on note en effet la présence
des dieux gaulois Taranis ici avec sa
roue et Kern avec sa ramure de
serre une autre plaque nous
intéresse on y voit au centre une déesse
qui se fait tresser les cheveux par une
servante
humaine la déesse lève la main droite
sur laquelle est posé un petit oiseau
tandis que deux grands volatiles
encadrent la scène d'en
haut
tout en bas gissent un chien et un homme
que la déesse semble-t-il en deuil tient
contre sa poitrine de son bras
gauche sur le côté est assise une femme
vêtue d'une longue robe et au-dessus
d'elle court un
quadrupède la scène globale obéit à la
même structure que celle du Dios oiseau
on y retrouve en effet en bas le héros
et son chien en haut deux oiseaux en
encadrement dont les becs sont tournés
vers une tête humaine au
[Musique]
centre le dieu aux oiseaux est présent
aussi sur du mobilier religieux au musée
de Bourges se trouve un diptique en
ivoire incrusté dans un cadre en bois
officiellement daté du 5e
siècle en haut un homme barbu en toge
est assis sur un trône
il tient dans sa main gauche une longue
cuillère dans sa droite un objet
difficile à déterminer il a deux enfants
à ses côtés et surtout perchés sur le
fronton deux oiseaux tournent leur bec
vers sa
tête ainsi Stelle statue et mobilier
d'époque gauloise offre la même image
d'un dieu barbu encadré par deux
oiseaux cette composante précise du dieu
encadré par deux oiseaux on va la
retrouver dans mainth église médiévale
où à l'évidence l'argolois a très bien
survécu les églises dites romane sont de
fait éminemment
[Musique]
celtiqu à viselet un chapiteau présente
deux scènes contigues qui mettent en
valeur un héros
utaturge le héros est encadré par deux
oiseaux juchés sur des feuillages les
deux volatiles d'os àau se retournent et
joignent leur bec au-dessus de la tête
de leur maître le saint homme se tient
debout il porte dans sa main droite un
verre rempli d'un élixir de son index
gauche il touche le crâne d'un homme
grimaçant accroupi qui agrippe un sac
dans chaque main le sein soigne un
malade de sa folie ou de sa
cupidité l'autre moitié du chapiteau est
plus esquinté on y reconnaît notre
guérisseur entouré de ces deux oiseaux
il se tient debout sur un homme allongé
au sol il semble que ses bras agripaient
une pince on y voit la langue de l'homme
comme saisie et tiré au
dehors peut-être est-il un
blasphémateur le maître aux oiseaux est
un redresseur de Thor dont le terrain
d'action est ici autant moral que
[Musique]
physique à Saint-Martin de becherville
un vieux barbu est entouré presque
assailli par une foule
suppliante notre héros tient dans sa
main gauche un objet dépliant comme des
tablettes qui pourraient contenir des
lois sa main droite est levée son index
tendu vers le ciel tel un maître qui
enseigne une
doctrine quant aux deux oiseaux
d'encadrement ils sont discrets mais
bien présents l'un a le bec dressé juste
à côté de la main droite de son maître
le fier volatile perché sur un appui y
déroule autour une longue queue
serpentiforme on note au passage la
qualité dialectique de l'image avec côte
à côte issée vers le ciel l'index du
maître le bec de l'oiseau et les mains
jointes d'un
suppliant le second oiseau est situé à
l'autre bout de la scène il est juché
sur les genoux d'un
suppliant l'éminence de l'orateur est
évidente mais qui
est-il aucun personnage de la Bible
n'est accompagné de deux
oiseaux son visage fourn un indice notre
homme porte sur la tête un curieux
Couvrechef qui lui fait deux petites
bosses au sommet du crâne tel les
endouillers naissants d'un
servidé on observe la même ramure sur
cette statue du musée de
langangre l'ancien dieug gaulois est ici
figuré avec trois
[Musique]
têtes le personnage est facilement
connaissable à ces petits bois de
[Musique]
serre sur le chaudron de gind d'estrupes
le dieu cornu carnunos est entouré
d'animaux tournés révérencieusement vers
lui et il brandit dans ses mains le
torque sacré et le
serpent cette mise en scène le rapproche
donc beaucoup du personnage figuré dans
l'église sur le Chaudon de gindestrupe
et à Saint-Martin de beucherville en
effet le héros spirituel porte des
cornes ramur ou Couvrechef Cornu il
tient en main l'autorité sacrée torque
ou tablettees des lois il est accompagné
d'un animal
serpentiforme serpent ou oiseau à queue
de serpent et il est entouré de ses
fidèles animaux ou
disciples ajoutons que par son Bram le
sert à le coffre sonore le plus puissant
du règne animal dans nos
régions ce qui en fait si l'on peut dire
l'orateur de la
forêt une fois humanisé le divin ser au
torque sacré devient un orateur
ecclésiastique en charge de la
[Musique]
loi dans une même église on voit parfois
se côtoyer le même concept théologique
sous deux versions
différentes la
animalisée le dieu aux oiseaux et la
version humanisée le dieu aux
anges c'est le cas à fontevrau sur cette
frise abîmée un bloc de pierre présente
à chaque angle le même
personnage un homme tient par le coup
deux oiseaux qui encadrent sa
tête il se tient à caliifourchon sur le
cou d'un lion on reconnaît le dieu aux
oiseaux et la suite de la frise est
intéressante d'abord une foule d'apôtres
nimbé se dirige vers la mise en bière
d'un divin
personnage placé dans un linceol le
défun est lui-même encadré par deux
anges puis vient une reine mère ou
épouse dans une mendor le tenue par de
ans
[Musique]
enfin nimbé d'une croix solaire le dieu
ressuscité trône sur un siège dans une
mendorle encadré toujours par deux anges
le Dieu fait homme brandit dans sa main
gauche l'écriture tandis que de la
droite il bénit le
monde ainsi le dieu encadré par deux
anges interprétés comme le Christ fait
le pendant du dieu encadré par deux
oiseaux du début de la
Frise si l'on compare fontevreau avec
Saint-Martin de becherville c'est le
même personnage qui est
représenté dans les deux cas en effet le
dieu fondateur porte un couvre-chef
ramur de serre croinb solaire il tient
dans la main gauche la doctrine tablette
livre il fait de la main droite levée un
signe
d'autorité il est entouré de ses
disciples et il est encadré par deux
créatures aériennes oiseaux
anges à Saint-Benoît surloire l'abaye de
Fleury présente plusieurs reliefs avec
le dieu aux oiseaux
[Musique]
les trois phases de ce chapitau montrent
le même jeune homme encadré par deux
aigles les mains du héros touchent
délicatement le plumage des puissants
volatiles chaque aigle est perché sur la
croupe d'un lion dont il MT la nuque
avec son
bec comme à fonevreau on retrouve
plusieurs points communs qui donnent la
composante
le dieu encadré par deux oiseaux
surmonte le lion on a donc tout lieu de
croire qu'il s'agit du même
personnage toujours àleuri sur la façade
nord on voit au centre le Dieu fait
homme nimbé les mains levées et ouvertes
pour bénir la foule il est debout dans
une mandorle tenue par deux
anges en haut à droite Dieu le Père est
nimbé d'une croix solaire il désigne le
Christ de sa main droite comme pour dire
celui-ci est mon
fils comme à fonevreau donc le Christ
est encadré par deux
[Musique]
anges le dieu aux oiseaux des anciens
Gaulois a manifestement été compris
comme une préfiguration du Dieu de
l'Évangile d'où la mise en scène
identique le dieu est encadré par deux
créat
aé l'abaye de Saint-Germain des prê à
Paris offre plusieurs chapitaux
archaïques ou récent où la tête sacrée
est encadrée et comme conseillée par les
deux
oiseaux ici la tête hybride est mi
humaine mi
animal dans la même église le buste du
héroglabre surgit en arrière d'une
grande feuille il est encadré par deux
oiseaux dont les B repose délicatement
sur le crâne de leur
maître les volatiles ont une pâte levée
sur l'épaule du jeune homme dans un
geste
protecteur enfin toujours à
Saint-Germain des pré les deux oiseau
encadr la Sainte Face d'un jeune homme
barbu et impassible chaque volatile pose
une pâte rassurante sur ses
épaules en bas il y a deux dragons
agressifs on serait tenté de reconnaître
qu ce jeune homme le Christ mais les
deux oiseaux n'ont rien de biblique et
renvoi clairement au dieux aux oiseaux
de la gaulle
antique sur la cathédrale de Bordeaux un
chapiteau archaïque montre la tête du
dieu encadré par deux oiseaux eux-mêmes
perchés sur deux fauves sans doute des
lions on reconnaît donc la même
composante iconographique à Bordeaux
fontevreau Saint-Benoît sur Loire et
Saint-Germain des Prés la tête du dieu
est encadrée par deux oiseaux et en bas
se trouvent les fauves lions ou
[Applaudissements]
dragons à saintmenou le visage massif du
dieu déploie une barbe fleurie de sa
bouche jaillissent deux rinceaux qui
remontent et donnent des fruits que
picorent les deux corbeaux placés aux
angles détails révélateurs des temples
du dieu sa deux petites excroissances
telles les endouillés d'un servidé sur
lesqueles sont d'ailleurs perchés les
deux
oiseaux il se dégage de la physionomie
du dieu la même propriété crânienne qu'à
Saint-Martin de
beuchervville et sur la statue à trois
visages de
Langre il ne peut s'agir que du même
personnage à savoir
kernunos les reliefs de ces églises
resterait muet si l'on devait les
exploiter Bible en main mais il
s'éclaire un peu à la lumière des
figures païennes de la gaulle antique
mes églises dit Troman semblent avoir
été à l'origine des sanctuaires
[Musique]
Gaulois au puit en Velet le visage barbu
surgit d'une corbeille gravé de rinceaux
entrelacés le dieu est encadré par deux
oiseaux perchés sur la bordure du
récipient l'homme a la bouche ouverte
comme s'il parlait et les deux pointes
de sa moustache finissent en
spirale à garbec les deux oiseaux à
visage humain sont coiffés d'un bonnet
ils accollent leur visage et encadrent
de leur corps la tête divine glabre il
déploient une longue queue
feuillue
la composante du diuxx oiseau présente
main de variantes preuve de la libre
créativité des artistes d'où des reliefs
parfois
surprenants à saint-sidroine ce
chapiteau présente deux oiseaux géants à
visage d'homme leur bouche est activée
par une main qui fait office de langue
ce qui laisse penser qu'ils ont l'usage
de la
parole chaque oiseau avance une patte
comme pour saisir la petite tête humaine
au centre la Sainte Face dégage force et
sérénité les deux volatiles vénèrent et
protègent le
dieu à plein pied les trois personnages
de la composante Dieu tête encadré par
deux oiseaux ont fusionné en un seul le
dieu est barbu et sa moustache finit en
pointe spiralée
les trous au niveau des yeux témoignent
de l'incrustation jadis de pierres
précieuse de cette tête partent deux
CPES volatiles l'ensemble forme donc un
oiseau à deux corps et une tête
humaine on note aussi que l'oiseau AG
gripe dans sa serre une
sphère
si l'on met en vis-àvis sains droit n
plein pied on observe que la sphère
correspond à la tête même du dieu d'où
la structure suivante le dieu tête est
encadré par deux oiseaux qui tiennent
dans leur serre la présence divine tête
ou
sphère il semble en effet que la sphère
contienne la présence divine un peu
comme dans le christianisme l'osti tient
la présence réelle du
Christ toujours à plein pied le
chapiteau d'à côté montre le même Dieu
tête avec Barbe et pointe de moustache
spiralé le dieu surmonte une feuille
épaisse et
longue à droite les deux oiseaux ont ici
les coups
enlacés chacun ramène son bec sous son
aile et empoigne une sphère dans sa
serre entre eux pousseent une plante à 5
feu la gestuelle des coups enlacés doit
avoir une signification car elle se
rencontre ailleurs par exemple à tournée
en
Belgique et à saint-benoî sur
Loire sur la frise sont perchés trois
oiseaux dont deux ont les coups
enlacés ils surmonte un servidé placé
sur la face du
chapitaau
l'association précise des oiseaux avec
un sert est à rapprocher de celle où les
oiseaux accompagnent un personnage
coiffé de bois naissant comme à
saintmenou et à Saint-Martin de
becherville que les oiseaux accompagnent
le SER le dieu tête ou le dieu orateur
il s'agit toujours du même Dieu
souverain
carnunos l'attitude générale de l'oiseau
indique sûrement quelque chose selon
qu'il nous son coup à
congénère ou comme ici qu'il accolle son
bec aux plumes de son
aile àoche l'oiseau se tourne vers
l'arrière comme pour poser son bec sur
son aile
idème en
binôme à fonevreau l'oiseau enfouie en
revanche son bec sous son aile et touche
son
[Musique]
ventre l'emplacement des oiseaux obéit
semble-t-il aussi à des critères
déterminés comme on a vu le dieu aux
oiseau se présente comme un visage
encadré par deux oiseaux
expressifs et cette tête possède parfois
des bois de
serre voire elle est carrément remplacée
par un
servidé or les deux oiseaux sont en
général situés au-dessus de cette tête
ou de ce ser et en outre leur attitude
est parlante soit leurs coups sont
enlacés comme à Saint-Benoît
surloire soit leur ser agripe la tête
comme à Saint-
cidroine soit leurs becs sont orientés
vers la tête comme à
mou soit leur bec picore les fruits des
rinceaux que produit la tête comme à
saintmenou et en face de cette structure
où la tête est d'un ser il existe
peut-être une structure opposée où la
tête est d'un lion comme à
mosac les deux oiseaux se situent alors
en dessous de la tête et leur bec s'en
détourne
même configuration à Saint nectter où
les oiseaux situés en bas se détournent
de la tête de lion situé en
haut à Guérande un félin Trô au centre
encadré par deux oiseaux qui se
détournent de
lui enfin à saint-réverérien les deux
oiseaux sont clairement situés sous la
tête de Lyon dont la gueule dégorge de
rinceaux de
[Musique]
feuillage durant l'Antiquité des auteurs
grecs font état d'un verger merveilleux
le jardin des espérides dont les pommes
d'or assurent l'immortalité à ceux qui
en
mangent et il le situait loin de chez
eux en
Occident en existe une composante
mythologique très précise que l'on
pourrait résumer par l'oiseau et la
sphère à mou on a vu que le Dieu aux
oiseau porte trois fruits on dirait des
pommes dans le creux de son
bras à reince une stelle galoromaine
présente le dieu kernunos encadré
d'hermè et Apollon qui semblent ici
remplacer les deux
oiseaux et le dieu barbu déverse de son
sac une masse de billes dont se repaisse
un ser et un
[Musique]
bœuf à la source de la scène en
Bourgogne régnait jadis la déesse
[Musique]
seekana une statue du 19e siècle
commémore le lointain passé sous la
forme d'une jeune femme sensuelle non
chalamment allongée et entourée de
symboles de
[Musique]
fécondité nos aïux Gaulois en avaient en
revanche une image plus austère le musée
de Dijon montre en effet une statue de
bronze datée du début de notre ère qui
figure
squana debout sur une barque la déesse
porte une couronne
elle est vêtue d'une longue robe plissée
elle tient dans ses mains des objets
aujourd'hui disparus corne d'abondance
sceptre ou
rame la poitrine plate et même serrée
par des cordons squana indique qu'elle
n'est pas une déesse maternelle ni
sensuelle elle serait plutôt liée à la
[Musique]
mort monnaises et bijoux lui étaient
donné en change de l'accomplissement
d'un
vœu c'est toutefois la barque qui nous
intéresse ici la barque de seekana
présente en effet une proue animale en
bec d'oiseau CNE ou
canard et chose remarquable le bec tient
une petite sphère plus ou moins de la
taille d'une
pomme la petite sphère équivaut
peut-être à l'obol cette pièce de
monnaie qu'autrefois les Grecs plaçaient
dans la bouche des morts pour leur payer
le péage vers
l'au-delà associé à la sphère et à
l'oiseau la DS aquatique Sequana était
donc apparemment chargée d'emmener sur
sa barque les âmes des défunts vers leur
destination
finale le musée lapidaire de bourgees
offre aux visiteurs une grande quantité
de monuments funéraires de l'époque
gauloise les pierres tombales ont en
général la forme d'un rectangle en
hauteur coiffé d'un
[Musique]
fronton sur les plus belles œuvres sont
figurés les défunts le tracé réaliste il
dévoile les traits du visage le statut
social et la
[Musique]
profession
en partance pour l'au-delà beaucoup de
ces défins emmènne donc avec eux les
attributs de leur vie
terrestre
mais le plus surprenant c'est que
certains voyageurs du temps tiennent
dans la main une sphère qui rappelle
celle que tient dans son bec l'oiseau de
Séquana ou les fruits du dieu aux
oiseaux mais qui sont ces personnages
s'agit-il vraiment toujours de défunt ou
parfois de
divinité sur cette superbe Stelle
funéraire un père porte son fils dans
les bras l'enfant tient une sphère dans
sa
main père et fils sont situés dans un
temple stylisé dont les deux piliers
sont surmontés d'un
fronton sur le fronton domine le char
solaire un jeune homme à la tête radiée
conduit un char à quat
chevaux on perçoit dans cette Stelle un
je ne sais quoi de préchrétien habitué
que nous sommes à voir Saint-Joseph
portant l'Enfant Jésus il n'a pas dû
être difficile de passer de l'art
celtique païen à l'art
[Musique]
chrétien il semble que l'enfant soit en
fait un enfant Dieu de l'ancien
paganisme on le retrouve seul sur cette
Stelle l'enfant se tient debout entre
deux piliers gravés de motifs il tient
une sphère dans sa main
e en haut deux têtes aux angles
encadrent le
fronton qui sont ces trois personnages
entre l'enfant et les deux têtes d'angle
on lit le mot
mercurialis c'est-à-dire de
mercure durant l'Empire c'est à mercure
que les Gaulois avaient assimilé leur
dieu
principal or ce dieu est parfois figuré
tricéphale comme à
Langre
[Musique]
on peut donc penser que cet enfant
Mercurial à trois têtes est le même
personnage que le kernunos barbu à trois
têtes ce type de Stelle présente sans
doute l'enfant dieu de la gaulle païenne
comme promesse de la vie
[Musique]
éternelle
sur cette hostelle un jeune homme se
tient entre deux piliers surmonté d'un
fronton avec une étoile tournante à six
[Musique]
branches le garçon tient une sphère dans
sa main
droite comme les deux enfants précédents
il s'agit peut-être là encore du dieu
sauveur et guide des
âmes ce garçon tient dans ses mains deux
sphères ovoïd qui ressem sememble à des
[Musique]
œufs probablement le même
personnage un enfant tient une sphère
dans son bras
gauche à côté de lui se trouve une
corbeille de
fruits au-dessus du fronton luit le
croissant de
lune l'oiseau est parfois présent
ici l'enfant tient un œuf dans sa main
droite et un oiseau dans sa main gauche
idem pour ce jeune homme qui porte un
oiseau sur son poignet gauche et
semblet-il un œuf dans sa main
droite voici un couple l'homme tient un
oiseau dans sa main
gauche l'index et le majeur de sa main
droite sont tendus vers l'oiseau comme
pour le désigner au
public si la sphère où l'œuf est
d'oiseau on peut alors imaginer la mort
comme une
renaissance le corps coquille se brise
et l'âme oiseau
[Musique]
s'envolle
cela expliquerait la présence fréquente
des sphères des oiseaux mais aussi des
symboles
cosmiques ce jeune homme ne tient pas de
sphèr mais il y y en a une dans le
triangle du
fronton fronton dans lequel trouve ici
un attelage à deux
chevaux le char est conduit par une
femme coiffée d'un croissant de
lune scène mythique vers l'au-delà où
lune sphère oiseau se répond d'une tombe
à
l'autre dès lors ce jeune homme à la
barbe légère est probablement un Dieu
sinon un défunt dans les pas du dieu un
peu comme un chrétien suit les pas du
Christ
ce personnage tient deux sphères dans sa
main gauche tandis que dans le fronton
lui le croissant de
lune le symbole se suffit à lui-même
ainsi le croissant de lune s'étire
pointes en haut ici surmonté de deux
volutes en
S la surmonté d'une
sphère
la Lune est soit encadrée par deux
[Musique]
colonnes soit ass dans le
fronton on note aussi la présence d'une
tour sous la
[Musique]
lune la Pomme de Pain est très fréquente
elle aussi souvent posé soit sur une
[Musique]
tour
soit sur une sorte de
[Musique]
piédestal ainsi pomme de pain lune
sphère et œuf étai jadis associés à la
mort et à la survie de l'âme telles les
pommes des
espérides message d'espérance envoyé
depuis un passé révolu par les pierres
tombales de la Gaule
[Musique]
païenne
dans nos églises celtique on retrouve
des éléments similaires aux pierres
tombales de l'antiquité
gauloise l'oiseau est associé à la
sphère à l'homme et parfois aux
spirales à plein pied on se souvient des
deux chapitauxx qui représentent le dieu
aux oiseaux sur l'un les deux oiseaux
ont les coups en la
chacun tient une sphère dans sa
patte à leur côté le dieu tête arbore
une belle barbe dont la moustache et les
pointes finissent en petite
Volut sur l'autre chapiteau c'est une
même créature qui combine le dieu tête
et les deux oiseaux chaque corps
d'oiseau agripe sa sphère et les deux
pointes de moustache se retrousent en
deux belles
spirales yant l'oiseau tend son coup en
arrière il tient une sphère calée entre
son bec et son aile son bec touche une
femme nue en
souffrance de l'autre côté un humanoïde
tire une énorme
langue on note le rinceau de volute
au-dessus de la tête de
l'oiseau à agetem un duel oppose l'homme
à l'oiseau géant qui agripe un fruit
dans son bec le fruit rond provient de
la tige entre les deux spirales
d'angle l'homme agripe d'une main l'aile
de l'oiseau de l'autre la tige d'ou pend
le
fruit à kzersberg trois oiseaux aux
ailes déployés tiennent chacun une
sphère calée entre bec et
cou à nein un superbe extérieur offre
une série de quatre oiseaux
personnalisés situés au-dessus d'une
rangée
d'arbuste groupé deux par deux les
volatiles ont les coups
enlacés sur ce premier du haut d'oiseau
le premier à gauche a le bec enfoui sous
son
aile son comparse à droite agripe et
engloutit de son bec le bout de la queue
d'un
serpent chaque oiseau tient ici dans sa
serre la fameuse
sphère on note entre les deux volatiles
une volumineuse
spirale le second duut d'oiseau offre
plus de
disparité ainsi le troisième oiseau
accroche de ces deux pattes le corps et
le cou du même serpent qui tire la
langue il n'y a ici aucune
sphère enfin le dernier oiseau saisit un
lion à la gueule et à l'épaule comme
pour l'enlever du
sol quant au lion perché à la cime d'un
arbre il tient dans ses pates avant une
[Musique]
sphère l'idée d'un fauve qui s'empare
d'une sphère céleste n'est pas isolé
dans la mythologie scandinave en effet à
la fin des temps deux loups engloutiront
le soleil et la
lune
on note que la gueule du lion se situe à
l'angle juste sous les coups enlacés des
oiseaux c'est-à-dire à l'endroit même de
la spirale sur l'autre groupe
d'oiseaux en résumé les oiseaux 1 et 2
tiennent des sphères ainsi que le lion
associé à l'oiseau
4 seul l'oiseau 3 n'a aucune sphère mais
il s'occupe vigoureusement du
serpent les oiseaux 2 et 3 saisissent le
serpent l'oiseau 4 le lion seul oiseau 1
ne saisit personne et se blottit sous
son
aile ces volatiles géants en lutte
contre un lion et un serpent semblent
vouloir dire plus qu'une simple
espérance en la vie dans
l'au-delà le chiffre 4 des oiseaux
indique peut-être les quatre saisons
avec par exemple les coups enlacés pour
les passages
d'équinoxe l'oiseau 1 sans relation avec
d'autres espèces enfouit son bec sous
son aile comme pour hiberner pendant la
morte saison il symboliserait
l'hiver l'oiseau de serait alors le
printemps saison triomphante qui dévore
par la queue le serpent des
ténèbres ces deux volatiles au cou
enlacés sont aussi les seuls à tenir en
propre une sphère symbole solaire de la
lumière
montante puis survient le solstice d'été
apogé mes déclins à venir du soleil
l'oiseau tro est le seul à n'avoir pas
pas de sphère il a comme perdu le soleil
mais règle son compte au
serpent qu'est donc devenu la sphère
céleste perchée sur la cime d'un arbre
elle est agrippée par les pattes d'un
lion l'oiseau 4 surgit en plein vol
comme pour la lui prendre et de sa quête
ramener la lumière pour le prochain
solstice
d'hiver même si ce chapiteau très
structurés ne dévoile pas tous ces
mystères on y reconnaît l'oiseau la
sphère et la spirale motif précis déjà
vu sur les pierres tombales antiques et
l'on comprend peut-être mieux le sens de
cette sphère à la fois salut de l'âme et
lumière
céleste d'où parfois la synthèse
théologique quand la sphère que tient
l'oiseau se présente comme la tête
sacrée de
Dieu on a vu à saint-sidroan la Sainte
Face réduite à la dimension d'une sphère
qui paraît flotter en
lévitation
de leurs ser tendues en avant les deux
oiseaux effleurent délicatement le
visage
divin configuration identique à Moissac
où deux oiseaux affrontés enserrent dans
leur pâte jointte un visage serin et
souriant cette posture singulière d'un
oiseau qui saisit de sa pâte levée un
objet sphérique se retrouve en science
héraldique par exemple l'écu de pelgru
présente grue qui agripe dans sa pâte
d'extre levé une pierre ronde ce caillou
porte le nom de vigilance vigilance face
au
danger même gestuel à gris ou ce sont
ici trois grues qui tiennent chacune
leur
vigilance la ressemblance est frappante
entre relief d'église et écu de ville
l'oiseau tient une sphère dans sa pâ
tendue qu'il s'agisse d'un œuf d'un
fruit d'un caillou ou d'une tête humaine
cette gestuelle précise témoigne à
l'évidence d'un héritage direct de
l'ancien
paganisme on se souvient en effet que
sur l'astelle de mou le dieu gaulois
dispose distinctement de ses attributs
il porte des oiseaux sur ses épaules et
des fruits dans sa
besacee ce qui donne la composante le
dieu l'oiseau et la
sphère cette composante explicite amène
s'interroger sur une coutume pittoresque
de la religion
catholique on dit qu'à pâqu au moment de
la mort du Christ les cloches s'envolent
vers Rome pour 3 jours de silence et de
[Musique]
deuil le troè jour elles s'envolent à
nouveau et reviennent à la cime de leur
clocher respectif annoncer bruyamment la
résurrection du
Christ clou du spectacle les enfants
sortent dans les jardins en quêtent des
œufs disséminés un peu
partout ainsi les cloches de bronze avec
leurs ail et leurs timbre Sonor sont à
considérer comme des créatures vivantes
aériennes et annonciatrices de la
résurrection de
Dieu ce qui fait de ces cloches volantes
les oiseaux de
[Musique]
Dieu les volatiles de l'ancien paganisme
tel celui de la DESS Sequana avait la
charge de transporter les œufs divins
auou fruits
[Musique]
d'immortalité d'où sur les tombes gooise
ces oiseaux et ses sphères que tiennent
les défuns en guise de salut de
l'âme un lien métaphysique unit la
résurrection de l'homme et la
résurrection de
Dieu comme souvent le christianisme
angul s'est fait le dépositaire des
rituels de l'ancienne culture
celtique
le passage progressif du paganisme au
christianisme s'accompagne d'une
métamorphose
figurative avec les siècles la
physionomie des oiseaux mythiques évolue
et acquire une forme plus
humaine on a vu qu'à saint-sidroine les
deux volatiles qui encadrent de leur
patte la tête de Dieu ont des visages
d'homme de la bouche des volatiles
sortent des mains pour exprimer qu'ils
sont doués de
paroles l'oiseau qui parle se rapproche
déjà évidemment de
l'ange à moi sac la frise de ce chapitau
en haut présent deux anges c'est-à-dire
des hommes pourvu
d'elle les deux créatures volantes
tiennent dans leur main un cercle dans
lequel apparaît un visage sans doute la
Sainte Face de
Dieu en version humanisée cette scène
rappelle celle dans la même abaylie des
deux oiseaux qui empoignent dans leur
serre la tête
humaine ainsi à saint-sidroine et à
Moissac on retrouve la même composant du
dieu aux oiseaux mais selon une
iconographie archaïque ou
moderne les deux créatures volantes et
humaines sont douées de paroles oiseau à
visage d'homme ou ange et elles tiennent
entre leurs membres pâes ou mains la
tête de
[Musique]
Dieu cette scène s'apparente évidemment
au célèbre die au oiseaux des anciens
Gaulois où le visage du dieu est encadré
par les deux oiseaux perchés sur ses
épaules à l'abaye de Saint-Benoît
surloire on se souvient du chapiteau où
deux oiseaux surplombent un servidé
Cornu et les deux oiseaux ont la
particularité d'être enlacés par le
cou on retrouve sur ce chapitau le même
enlacement d'oiseau qui surplombe ici un
enfant en bas deux griffons sont face à
face le griffon est un hybride mi lion
mi
aigle on note enfin la présence d'un
disque volumineux bien en vu sur la face
du chapiteau qui s'apparente évidemment
à la
sphère cette scène présente des
similitudes structurelles avec le
chapiteau de neandin où deux oiseaux ont
des coups enlacés et l'un des volatiles
saisit dans ses serres un lion qui tient
une
sphère
cela donne la composante oiseaux enlacés
lion sphère dans les deux cas en effet
en haut les coups des deux oiseaux sont
enlacés en bas les éléments lion et
oiseau sont associés soit sous la forme
hybride du Griffon soit le lion est
saisi par
l'oiseau enfin au niveau médian il y a
une
sphère cette configuration précise avec
ses personnage et leur gestuel semble
avoir évolué vers la modernité sous des
traits plus
humanisés ainsi ce chapiteau de
Saint-Benoît surloire présente en haut
un couple enlacé il est encadré par deux
personnages apparemment ailés donc des
anges placés sous les spirales
d'angles celui de droite tient une
sphère dans sa main droite
levée
celui de gauche lève sa main gauche
ouverte le couple enlacé surplombe un
enfant encadré par des
lions l'enfant possède des cornes de ses
mains il agripe les pattes des lions en
retour le lion de droite lui pose sa
pâte sur l'épaule tandis que le lion de
gauche tient dans sa pâte une
sphère
on note que les sphères sont situées en
opposition celle que tient l'ange est en
haut à droite celle que tient le lion
est en bas à gauche et comme pour
indiquer la chute de la sphère dans la
Pte du lion la main de l'ange qui
surmonte ce lion a la main ouverte donc
vide il est révélateur de rencontrer ici
et là les mêmes thèmes ne diffèr que la
facture araïsante ou moderne par exemple
sur ces deux chapitauxx on trouve la
composante du duo avec le jeune héros en
haut le duo
enlacé deux humains ou deux
oiseaux en bas la présence du jeune
héros enfant Cornu ou
servidé ce rapprochement permet de
confirmer que le jeune héros est un
homme servidé donc le dieug Gaulois
kernunos sur ces chapitaauux on note que
la sphère est tenu par le Lion et le
lion pose ses pates soit sur l'enfant
ser soit sur
l'arbre or le servidé par ces bois et
l'arbre fait de bois sont par définition
tous deux liés au thème du bois on peut
donc se demander si la rangée d'arbre en
bas du chapitau ne serait pas
l'équivalent du
servidé on aurait ici une composante
complexe sur la créature
boisée en haut le duo enlacé deux
humains ou ou de
oiseaux en bas des
lions un jeu de
sphère enfin la créature boisée hom S ou
arbre ainsi en confrontant les
chapitauxx entre eux on se rend compte
que certaines séquences se répètent et
les signes abstraits loin d'être un
simple décor ne sont pas à
négliger
on note en effet une composante
intéressante l'arbre porte la sphère à
sa cime et côtoie la spirale à nein les
deux oiseaux de gauche agripent chacun
une sphère dans leur
serre chaque sphère est située juste
au-dessus d'un arbre et entre les deux
sphères se trouve une
spirale à Dijon un chapiteau offre une
configuration similaire en haut niché
dans un cadre on reconnaît le même arbre
stylisé avec le Tron central les deux
branches épaisses qui retombent sur les
côtés et la sphère au
sommet l'arbre est encadré à gauche par
une série de cercles
concentrique et à droite par une
spirale on y décelle donc la structure
arbre sphère
spirale l'arbre se compose d'un tronc et
deux branches
tombantes sa cime ouverte côtoie une
sphère et une spirale se trouve à
côté tous ces reliefs si différents de
primabord renvoient en fait au même
corpus
mythologique l'origine païenne celtique
est
évidente par contraste on aurait du mal
à rapprocher ces scènes précises et
parenté à des épisodes de la
[Musique]
Bible en général les oiseaux encadrent
le visage impassible du dieu au
[Musique]
centre
parfois les oiseaux se métamorphosent et
deviennent des volatiles hybrides à
visage
[Musique]
d'homme enfin les oiseaux celtiques
deviennent des anges qui encadr la
Sainte Face du dieu
[Musique]
souverain le dieu aux oiseaux des
anciens Gaulois tels qu'il est figuré
Amou a donc survécu et diversement
évolué dans maines églises du haut
moyenâge de toute la
France
dans les textes médiévaux français les
oiseaux mythiques de la Gaulle se sont
métamorphosés en an
[Musique]
gardien les anges servent charlemain
dans les chansons de geste un peu comme
ils servent Dieu dans les
églises selon la matière de France en
effet Charlemagne et son neveu Roland
sont normalement les deux seuls
personnages en rapport direct et
bienveillant avec les
anges même si ce n'est pas toujours le
même seint Michel Gabriel Jacques voire
un anonyme langange des poèmes épiques
vient toujours du ciel vole dans les
airs et se soucie de Rolland et
Charlemagne
en tant que souverain charlemagne a un
rapport plutôt intellectuel avec l'ange
d'où leur dialogue notamment lors de
songes
prémonitoir ainsi en est-il au début de
la geste du roi contre les
Sarasins selon la Chronique de Turpin
tandis que d'or Charlemagne un saint
vient lui annoncer sa future mission
sous la forme d'une vision
onirrique il vint à Charles une vision
où il voyait un chemin d'étoile un beau
seigneur de grande taille lui apparut de
nuit je suis Jacques dit-il l'apôtre de
Jésus-Christ le chemin d'étoiles que tu
as vu signifie que tu dois aller de
France en Galy avec une grande armée
pour combattre les Sarasin délivrez ma
route et ma terre visiter mon Église et
mon
tombeau vision onirrique et apparitions
de l'âme sainte sont ici clairement lié
il s'agit de l'aide apportée au Roi par
le ciel
dans la Chanson de Roland on retrouve la
même mise en scène qui commence et qui
clot tout l'épisode de
[Musique]
roncevau au début du poème le traître
Ganelon se rend chez les Sarrasins et
fomente avec eux un complot pour
attaquer l'arrière-gard de Franck dans
les
[Musique]
Pyrénées le seul Fran prévenu de cette
trahison et
Charlemagne et il est de façon
surnaturelle grâce à un songe
prémonitoire dans cette fresque onirique
Charles voit d'abord Ganelon lui briser
la
lance puis des scènes de chasse
désignent certains duels à venir Ganelon
prend la forme d'un sanglier et Rolland
d'un chien de
chasse le jour va la nuit est tombée le
puissant empereur Charles dort il fait
un songe il était au plus haut col de S
et tenait sa lance à la hampe de freine
quand le comte Ganelon la lui saisit des
mains il la secoua et l'agita si
violemment que les éclats en volèrent
jusqu'au ciel Charles dort et ne
s'éveille pas après ce songe il a une
autre vision il était en France dans sa
chapelle d'X un sanglier très cruel lui
mordait le bras droit des ardenes il vit
venir un léopard qui avec fureur
l'assaillit en personne depuis la salle
dévala un vôtre par bons et par saut il
accourut à Charles il trancha d'abord
l'oreille droite du sanglier puis avec
colère combattit le
léopard tel est l'amorce de roncevau
l'ange envoie au roi Charles un songe
prémonitoire et au terme de la bataille
finale l'ange prend la parole et décide
ainsi de l'issue du duel de
roi
l'ange en lui-même n'est pas un guerrier
mais sa présence au-dessus de la mêlée
suffit à faire pencher la victoire dans
le camp des
francs après la mort de Roland en effet
une seconde bataille a lieu où
Charlemagne affronte en duel les mir
Baligant et l'intervention verbale de
l'ange est
décisive sa simple voix sa céleste
apostrophe rend aussitôt vigueur à
l'empereur des Frans qui malgré blessure
à la tête triomphe de son
ennemi Baligan frappe Charlemagne sur le
HME d'acier Bruni le lui brise je lui
fend sur la tête il lui met l'épée sur
les cheveux dru prend une pleine paume
et plus de chair Charle chancelle pour
un peu il a l'échoir mais Dieu ne veut
qu'il soit tué ni vaincu Saint Gabriel
vient vers lui et lui demande grand roi
que
fais-tu quand Charles entend la sainte
voix de l'ange il n'a ni PE ni crainte
de la mort il a repris sa vigueur et ses
esprits il frappe les mires de l'épée de
France brise son hom au gemme
flamboyante tranche sa tête la cervelle
se répand et tout son visage jusqu'à la
barbe blanche il la bat mort sans espoir
il crie Monjoie pour se faire
reconnaître ainsi dans la Chanson de
Roland la guerre contre les Sarasin est
précisément
encadré au début par un signe angélique
le songe prémonitoire qui avertit
Charlemagne de la trahison de
Ganelon et à la fin par l'ange en
personne qui sauve Charlemagne au cours
de l'ultime
duel présent à l'aube et au crépuscule
de la bataille l'ange plane au-dessus
des événement et en oriente
l'issue c'est l'ange qui remet la
célèbre épée Durandal au roi Charlemagne
pour que celui ici la confie à son
meilleur guerrier le roi des Francs la
donne bien sûr à son neveu
Roland c'est l'une des versions de
l'acquisition de Durandal par
Roland sentant sa fin proche le
chevalier mourant parle ainsi à son épée
e Durandal comme tu es claire et
brillante comme tu resplendis et
flamboises au soleil Charles était dans
le Val de la Morienne quand Dieu lui
envoya du ciel son ange pour qu'il te
donnâ à un compte qui serait le chef de
son armée c'est ainsi que le grand et
noble roi me
l'assignit par une autre chanson on sait
que juste après son adoubement trois
chevaliers blancs sont descendus des
montagnes et que l'un d'eux donna à
Roland l'invincibilité sur le champ de
bataille trois chevaliers au Galot
descendent du flanc d'une montagne au
les apostrophes à voix haute quel est
votre nom guerrier au grand cheval
l'autre répond là d'où je suis on
m'appelle George et partout j'ai le
premier coup sur le champ de bataille
mais je le donne aujourd'hui à cet
enfant confie-le-moi à cette condition
personne ne pourra jamais le tuer Dieu
va montrer aux chrétiens qu'il veut les
avoir pour lui à
[Musique]
jamais à ces tris saints aériens venus
le jour de son baptême du fer répondent
trois anges qui viennent le jour de sa
mort pour emener l'âme de Roland au
Paradis le comte Roland se couche sous
un pain il présenta son gant droit à
Dieu Saint- Gabriel de sa main lui appr
pris Roland a penché sa tête sur son
bras et les mains jointes é allé à sa
fin Dieu lui envoya son ange chérubin et
Saint-Michel du péril de la mer et avec
eux 20 Saint Gabriel ils emportent l'âme
du compte au
Paradis ces trois anges ne sont pas
n'importe qui leur nom est et leur rôle
respectifs les identifient clairement
aux fameuses trois fonctions
indo-européennes le sacré la guerre et
la
production or la Trinité d'ange qui se
porte auprès de Roland Mourand porte en
elle ses trois fonctions précises
Gabriel par son rôle dominant de
messager de Dieu est l'ange de fonction
souveraine Michel de fonction guerrière
est l'ange combattif qui terrasse le
dragon de
l'Apocalypse quant à chérubin son nom
générique renvoie plus à une catégorie
d'anges qu'un pers
identifiable Sélange de la trè
fonction cet organigramme théologique à
l'origine a par la suite éta adapté à la
société toute entière sous la forme des
trois corps des États généraux le clergé
la noblesse et le tiers
état ces trois anges tels lesores
scandinaves les Moires greces et les
parces romaines veill donc à la destinée
des héros
sur le chaudron de gindestrup on
retrouve cette trinité aérienne sous la
forme de trois oiseaux justement auprès
du héros et son
chien sur le pilier des NES à Paris les
trois oiseaux sont des
grues il est probable que les trois
matâres dont l'une porte un enfant sont
une version humanisée des trois grues
idem pour les trois souffleur de carnix
en rapport ici avec la mort et le cycle
de
renaissance dans nos chansons de geste
on note que l'ange apparaît soit triple
en général au côté de Roland soit seul
surtout auprès de
Charlemagne l'ange est toujours
bienveillant quoique sévère plus ancien
et plus mature que Charlemagne il
remplit auprès du roi un rôle de guide
ou de vieil éducateur
expérimenté son rôle d'éclaireur céleste
traverse les générations puisqu'il
officie aussi bien auprès du vieux
Charlemagne que du jeune
Rolland l'ange n'a pas d'arme ou elle ne
serait que d'apara en fait son arme
c'est sa parole sa voix revigore son
destinataire ce qui permet par exemple à
un Charlemagne blessé de remporter son
duel enfin selon la tradition l'ange est
de couleur blanche et évidemment il est
célibataire y aurait-il une structure
sous-jacente à ce singulier personnage
cet ange au contour si précis n'est pas
un personnage inventé par les jongleurs
de l'époque féodale mais l'héritier
directe d'une très vieille tradition
culturelle l'ange correspond au dieu
cadre
le dieu cadre doit son nom au professeur
George duumésil dont l'œuvre immense a
exploré en profondeur l'âme culturelle
de nos lointains ancêtres
indo-européens comment définir le dieu
[Musique]
cadre
dans l'ancienne cosmogonie c'est le dieu
céleste par excellence avec toutefois
des attributs intellectuels et non pas
guerriers ce qui le différencie du
roi un parallèle avec d'autres dieux
cadres permettra de mieux cerner la
teneur du
personnage
en Scandinavie le rôle de cadre est
dévolu au dieu hemdal
emdal est le plus ancien des dieux ce
qui lui confère la sagesse et un rôle de
guide mais cette précéance chronologique
n'en fait pas le roi c'est Odin le roi
des
dieux cette distinction hemdal odin est
fondamentale hemdal est le premier par
la naissance donc le guide odin est le
premier en
donc le
roi un peu comme l'ange et le roi
Charlemagne le domaine d'emdal est le
ciel il y culmine en haut de
l'arc-en-ciel d'où il surveille le monde
entier toujours en éveil sa fonction de
guide en fait le
guetteteur c'est à lui qu'il incombe de
prévenir les dieux quand commencera
l'ultime bataille cosmique le Ragnarok
et c'est aussi emdal qui livrera le
dernier duel contre le démon
Loki il est donc au tout début et à la
toute fin du Ragnarok comme l'ange est
au tout début et à la toute fin de
ronevau hemda les
Trinitaires sous le nom de rig en effet
il engendre les trois ordres de la
société humaine que sont les serviteurs
les hommes libres et les nobles cette
trinité d'emdal rejoint la Trinité de
l'ange
emdal ne détient pas une arme
particulière lance ou épée mais il est
dit que son arme est sa propre tête or
on a vu que l'ange a comme arme le son
de sa
voix enfin emdal est déclaré le plus
blanc des dieux et il n'est pas
[Musique]
marié
si l'on résume les données sur le dieu
cadre en France et en Scandinavie on
obtient le tableau suivant le dieu cadre
est céleste l'ange descend du ciel
dal siège en haut de
l'arc-en-ciel il est de couleur blanche
et
célibataire sa primoté ancestrale en
fait le guide du roi Charlemagne ou
Odin le dieu cadre ne règne pas lui-même
il avertit conseille et protège il est
parfois trinitaire trois anges ou le
géniteur des trois ordres sociaux son
arme est cérébrale la voie de l'ange la
tête
d'emdal enfin le dieu cadre encadre
l'ultime bataille roncevau le
Ragnarok l'héritage commun français
scandinave est frappant de précision
mais on le trouve aussi
ailleurs à Rome le rôle de veilleur omni
pr omniscient bien qu'en retrait des
affaires du monde correspond au dieu
Janus l'idée d'encadrement se reflète
sur son double visage qui encadre
l'année en Inde le dieu cadre correspond
au héros arien bishma bishma est
l'incarnation du dieu céleste du
c'est-à-dire le jour duu en sanscrit est
issue de la même racine que dne en
français ou d en
anglais
en Iran le protecteur du roisal est le
Simorg un oiseau discret fabuleux et
intemporelle dont la fonction
bienveillante équivaut à l'ange auprès
du roi
Charlemagne pour en savoir plus sur
leudu cadre il faut lire myth et épopé
de Georges du mésil notamment les
séquences page 210 et
[Musique]
le dieu cadre est donc un personnage
complexe précis qui orbite autour du
dieu souverain ce duo complémentaire est
très bien conservé dans tout l'espace
indo-européen en Scandinavie le roi Odin
et le cadre
hemdal à Rome le roi Jupiter et le cadre
Janus en Inde le roi Indra et le cadre
du ou bishma en Iran le roi zal et le
Simorg en France le roi Charlemagne et
l'ange la structure qui associe le roi
et le dieu cadre remontant au lointaine
héritage indo-européen il est logique
qu'en France elle soit passée par la
culture
gauloise d'où le lien explicite entre le
légendaire Charlemagne assisté de l'ange
et le Dieu aux oiseaux de la gaaule
antique le dieu celtique que l'on voit
sur les stelles de mou et de Dierre sous
boui trouve ici un début
d'interprétation ce dieu barbu encadré
par deux oiseaux perchés sur ses épaules
et accompagné d'un chien à ses pieds
anticipe structurellement le charlemain
légendaire des chansons de gestes d'une
part charlemain est guidé par le dieu
cadre qui est l'ange héritier de
l'oiseau antique d'autre part il est
fendu par Roland qui dans le songe a
précisément la forme d'un chien de
chasse on y retrouve donc les mêmes
personnages quant à l'encadrement celui
du dieu gaulois par les deux oiseaux est
spatial tandis que celui du roi franc
par les deux intervention de l'ange est
temporelle la composante commune antique
médiévale est la suivante le souverain
barbu Dieu aux oiseaux ou roi
Charlemagne est guidé par le
bienveillant Dieu cadre oiseau ou
ange ce dieu cadre encadre le souverain
soit spatialement avec deux oiseaux sur
les épaules du dieu gaulois soit
temporellement avec deux interventions
angéliques auprès de
Charlemagne enfin le souverain est
protégé par son chien fidèle chien ou
Rolland le recours aux chansons de
gestes permet aussi d'expliciter des
reliefs d'église tel la scène où le dieu
aux oiseaux surmonte de
lion le dieu se présente toujours au
centre le visage
serein les deux oiseaux l'encadrent avec
bienveillance tout en attaquant le lion
ou le fauve qui en bas lève sa gueule
[Musique]
menaçante
la Chanson de Roland donne une réponse
possible on a vu que dans un songe
prémonitoire charlemag se voit affronter
un lion lion qui dans la bataille n'est
autre que l'émire Baligan
dans ce duel intervient l'ange qui par
sa parole encourageante insuffle au roi
des Francs l'énergie de la
victoire il s'agit donc du même
événement mythique que sur les reliefs
d'église dans les deux cas en effet le
souverain est accompagné du dieu cadre
élé le Dieu et l'oiseau Charlemagne et
l'ange et le cadre intervient de façon
décisive contre le L
il convient d'insister sur le fait que
ces reliefs d'église demeureraient
totalement obscur si l'on s'évertuait à
les interprété avec une
bible en France les sanctuaires
communément appelés église romane sont
dépositaires de la culture ethnique de
l'ancienne
gulle le dieu aux oiseaux des églises de
France n'est ni le Christ ni un saint
mais la survivance de l'ancien Dieu
souverain des
Celtes
selon le degré d'archaïsme culturel des
œuvres les mêmes personnages se
présentent sous la forme animale ou
humaine ainsi le dieu ser kernunos
apparaît ici avec sa puissante ramure
surmonté d'oiseaux au cou
enlacés le même Dieu offre un visage
humanisé avec des excroissances cornues
sur lesquelles sont perchés des
oiseaux
là le visage du dieu est totalement
humain et les oiseaux montrent eux aussi
un visage
humain enfin le dieu souverain en
majesté sur son trône est encadré par
deux anges qui tiennent la
mendole lors du passage à l'écriture les
anciens récits des bardes sont devenus
les chanson de
geste le dieu aux oiseaux survit en
Charlemagne et les oiseaux en
gardien au gré des circonstances et des
époques l'iconographie change et les
personnages se
métamorphosent mais surtout si l'on veut
bien prendre un temps de réflexion c'est
notre propre regard qui
évolue de nos jours sur certains relief
d'église on croit reconnaître le Christ
ou Moïse ou un saint quelconque là où un
franc des croix aurait reconnu
Charlemagne et un Gaulois d'entant
[Musique]
kernunos